okay breaking news right it
sounds like our activism worked donald
trump's postmaster general louis de joy
will be suspending reforms and
initiatives
for the post office until after the
november election
according to a draft statement that
reuters
is reporting on great news right dejoy
says i'm suspending these initiatives
until after the election
this is being done to avoid even the
appearance of impacting
election related mail we won right guys
except not so fast not so fast at all
this is not what it seems
this announcement is the post office
will not be changing
retail hours existing mail collection
boxes will remain where they are
no more mail processing facilities will
be closed but notice that absent
is the answer to the question what
happens to what you've already done
so there's a couple of different things
here that we have to talk about first of
all
at some surface level i mean okay good
right i don't wanna
i don't wanna dismiss this as nothing
the activism the sounding the alarm
the pulling to joy in uh to answer
questions before
lawmakers it led to an announcement that
more isn't going to be done that's good
i guess and and we should recognize that
but the reality is that the damage may
have already been done the changes that
they've made
already have been done in
disproportionately blue areas
to restrict delivery of mail to create
pileups and his statement says nothing
about
we're also going to undo all of the
things we've done in the last three
weeks
it says they will be suspending future
changes
until after the election so i don't know
about you
but i'm not particularly reassured by
this he may have already done what
needed to be done
in the blue voting areas and this could
be an announcement in fact
to give a false sense of security so
just remember these people are not our
friends
we have no reason to trust them he has
done a huge amount of damage
some sorting machines have been
dismantled some collection boxes have
been closed
so the idea that this is a victory of
accountability
where we now don't have to worry about
this we fixed it we won guys now
everything's fine with the mail
for the purposes of the upcoming
election it ignores reality and
i don't think i'm being too cynical by
saying this although
if you think i am let me know the other
part of this that really needs to be
restated
is that this announcement is not a
license to say
i now don't need to worry and i'll just
send my absentee ballot the day before
the election
and be confident that it's going to be
counted again
they are not undoing the damage that
they have already done as far as we can
tell in as far as has been stated so far
so if it were me and i am in this
position in the sense that
i'm voting absentee and i will have to
make a decision about
how and when i send in my ballot i would
return the ballot as soon as possible
if you're mailing it if you have the
ability to
drive it to a ballot box i would do that
as well and that's actually my plan
here in massachusetts i will be bringing
my ballot
to city hall if i ever get it i told the
story yesterday of how
i actually still have not received my
ballot for the primary
which is september 1. i requested it at
this point something like 13 14 days ago
and i would encourage other people to
just make sure you have
a plan that makes sense based on what's
happening in your state
based on where you can drop off ballots
in your state and don't make your plan
on the basis of a false sense of
security from this announcement that's
the most important
message i think they have done a bunch
of stuff
and now they're trying to get everybody
to forget about this by saying hey you
know what
to avoid the appearance of of maybe
affecting election mail
we're not going to be making any more
changes
well they've already done a bunch of
stuff we just don't know
the full extent of it we don't know the
full extent of what what's been taken
offline so we we just can't chance it is
the point and at the end of the show
today
during the voicemail segment i am going
to be talking
a little more about the ballot drop-off
situation
and how it really varies from state to
state and of course
that also makes this complicated we're a
country of 50 states
plus dc plus some territories and we
have
50 different election systems
essentially
with dramatically different rules in
each state in terms of how primaries and
elections are done where ballots can be
dropped off
and so much more so i'm going to address
that a little bit more later in the
program